I have some very exciting news for
everyone I am going to be an uncle
shut up computer who told him he can
talk this is my moment uncle it is so
Wednesday you guys might think that I
will be singing a song about John
Green's baby but I didn't know he was
going to make that announcement
yesterday I thought he was going to make
it tomorrow so I was not prepared for
that this is as best I could do John
Green loves John Green's baby it's gotta
be freaking cute but now it's time for
me to talk about the project for also MA
this is actually my project for awesome
video this year my money is going to my
all-time favorite environmental charity
in the Nature Conservancy our dad worked
for the Nature Conservancy when we were
growing up he was the florida state
director and it's an amazing
organization and basically their entire
mission is to buy land so that it does
not get destroyed and they do this
across the entire world they are a
global thing and they buy the land and
save it for ever the earth is much
better at keeping us alive than we are
we like biodome didn't work we couldn't
even do it wasn't called bio done was it
that was the poly store move but
whatever that thing was called we can't
do it and so we have to you know like
not completely destroy it and that's the
Nature Conservancy's one and only job to
save the last best places so I am going
to be giving a thousand dollars of my
money to the Nature Conservancy and I'm
going to be giving some of your money to
the Nature Conservancy because I am
auctioning off this is exciting for me
the actual hand-drawn cover of so jokes
this is the original cover as drawn by
shark eye Jones signed by me and shark
eye Jones and the CD itself the original
drawings done in pen I am putting them
on eBay right now and there will be
links to those eBay auctions in the
sidebar and we are also auctioning off a
single John Green bobblehead signed by
both John and Hank green all of the
money from my auctions will be going to
the Nature Conservancy and all the money
from John's auctions the glasses and the
bobble head will be going to stop
malaria this is what the Prophet Cross
was about people and I am extremely
excited here's my song John I will see
you tomorrow
well I might seem like a pretty happy
guy gimme a close look at my wife and
I'm sex fine but just because I'm happy
doesn't mean that I'm a man that most
people can't do in great math and a lot
of people think that you were - laughs
you've read a single book since high
school since winter being smart start
being a disgrace it's that kind of crap
that makes me hate this place
and if you don't hate it too there must
be something wrong with you I hate this
world so come hate it with me there's so
much screwed up crap makes me so freakin
side this world so let's get together
because there's nothing like hate to
motivate us to make this world war great
three species go extinct every day and
I'm scared to hell of climate change
300,000 people died and our fur and no
one tried to stop I don't know where we
were
we spend 2 billion per year on cosmetic
surgery imagine how many hungry children
that would feed an American girl start
dieting at 8 that kind of crap is why I
hate this place
and if you don't hate it too there must
be something wrong with you I hate this
world so come hate it with me there's so
much screwed-up crap we have got to give
back I hate this world so let's get
together because there's nothing like
hate to motivate us to make this world
more great yeah there's nothing like
more great
[Music]